le rôle de méchant de mes rêves alors je
rêve de jouer un mec très très
antipathique très impatient ça c'est un
truc j'ai toujours rêvé faire j'ai
peut-être un projet où ça se profile un
peu mais qui est très vite exaspéré par
quelqu'un qui tu vois quelqu'un qui par
exemple un tout petit peu de bruit à
côté de moi alors
on fait une interview avec voilà tu es
gentil ouais merci merci ce genre de ce
genre de température très très
facilement irritable et vraiment connard
en fait donc ça Julie j'aimerais bien
puis après il y a un peu l'archétype
plus attendu du méchant dans James Bond
donc à la fois méchant et élégant avec
un plan un plan machiavélique très très
bien rodé